uh  uh  it takes great bravery to make the sort  of allegations that have been made and  it's very important that we make that  clear from the start  um  the allegations are serious and they  need to be fully investigated i think at  this stage is for me to say what should  happen as a result but  it takes guts and bravery to come  forward to make allegations  like this  they now need to be fully investigated  either  by the conservative party or  um  by the criminal authorities but  those allegations having been made that  now needs to be an investigation into  them  as to the outcome that obviously depends  on the investigation